p-tech mom Zef it seems that there are
first results on the consultation on
summer time could you share this
resource with us and maybe comment them
well
one knows that the season starts when
leaks starts so I will not go into
discussing any numbers or leaks that are
being floated around what I can tell you
is that this public consultation and
summer time is something that the
Commission has organized so it does not
happen in a political vacuum it was us
that wanted a public consultation also
in following up the European Parliament
resolution on this same subject what I
can tell you is that of course you know
that this public consultation of massive
unprecedented scale ended on the 16th of
August with 4.6 million responses it is
the highest number of responses ever
received in a commissioned public
consultation Commissioner will let a
bulge
who's in charge will inform the College
of Commissioners of the results of the
consultation at the seminar today into
tomorrow and Friday because we feel that
is for the College of Commissioners
first to get a proper feedback from the
Commission and in charge and then a
formal report will be tabled with the
official results you give me the
opportunity to say that then we will
consult again with Parliament and
stakeholders because a consultation is
is not a referendum it's it's an element
that would take account when we come up
with our policy recommendations which
are for later so we we prefer to stay
with this sequence approach rather than
discuss numbers because some numbers
have been published somewhere
yes please Ricardo so finish
broadcasting I had your calling before
huh sorry thank you go ahead it is
possibly replace Adama sir will the
president say something about this
consultation because clearly it's very
close to the concerns of the citizen
would you say something in the State of
the Union upon a more in and then quite
a lot of the participants in this
consultation the people who responded
were Germans apparently now what do you
think about that is it does it make it
less representative at all if a vast
number of them two-thirds I think we're
in fact German from one member state
anyway okay again on the content of the
State of the Union speech I will not
spill the beans I want everybody to stay
tuned I said earlier you will not regret
it on the nature of the replies and the
responses what I can tell you leader is
that citizens from all EU Member States
took part in this public consultation
and we intend when we draft the report
to present the distribution of the
replies we received by country and more
generally by stakeholder group area of
activity etc so our reporting will not
be a dry reporting of numbers but we
will try to spell out the
characteristics that pertain to the
replies we received and as I said
earlier this consultation is an
important step it's something that we
wanted we're very happy that so many
people found it interesting but it's not
the only element that we will take into
account when we will present the policy
recommendations anything else
follow-up yes
so you see this is not the only element
you'll take into account which other
elements for example will you really
take into account when you possibly
present a recommendation or not and and
when when when is the report going to to
come out you already have a date I think
I missed that the report will come out
soon soon sooner rather than later
and what else we will take out we will
take into account well we have I don't
know you've seen it there is a European
Parliament resolution back in February
that has specific suggestions for us so
it is only normal that we would have to
discuss with Parliament with Parliament
reporters with the political groups with
stakeholders and of course the
consultation and that would give us a
rather I would say accurate picture of
the situation before we come up with our
proposal policy recommendations which
rest assured we'll always be according
to the principle of subsidiarity and
we'll respect as much as possible the
requirements that the European
Parliament as